[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا فيكم حياكم الله يا ضيوف
الرحمن شرفتونا واسعدتونا في طيبه طيبه في
المدينه المنوره في مزارع عاليه المدينه
الله يحييكم يا مرحبا فيكم تتعالى اصوات
هذا المزارع ترحيبا وتهليلا بزوار مزارع
عاليه المدينه طوال خمسه اعوام ودون مقابل
مالي اذ حول هذه النخيل الى متحف حي ياخذ
الزوار في تجربه فريده يروي من خلالها
تاريخها وثقافتها اهالي المنطقه
بمختلف اشكالها هناك المزرعه مقهى متكامل
الشاهي المدينه بالورد وبالنعناع والقهوه
السعوديه سوق الحرف اليدويه قرص الملا قرص
الجمر من تاريخنا مبيعات التمور عجوه
العاليه الحمد لله في اقبال من ضيوف
الرحمن
يستانسوا انبسطوا عندنا موقع للاحجار
الكريمه ودخول المزرعه مجانا لضيوف الرحمن
يسعدونا جلس ساعه ساعتين ثلاث ساعات على
قلوبنا زي العسل ونفرح بهم والله يحييهم
[موسيقى]
بساتين ومزارع النخيل بمنطقه عاليه
المدينه
ارتبطت تاريخيا بالسيره النبويه
وتتميز بانتاج العجوه التي تلقى رواجا
كبيرا في شهر رمضان اعضاء للنبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم اللي هي سبع البساتين اللي
يملكها سيدنا مخيريق النظري اللي هي هذه
الدلال والاعواف وحسنى والصافيه وميثب
وبرقه ومشربه ام ابراهيم يحرس المعتمرون
القادمون من مكه على زياره المسجد النبوي
والمواقع التاريخيه والدينيه في شهر رمضان
والتي تزخر بها المدينه المنوره
من المدينه المنوره سلطان السلمي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات